quatre milliards et demi de francs c'est
l'effort de l'état pour l'art en fête
principaux bénéficiaires les familles et
les personnes âgées
l'irlande du nord visite surprise de
margaret thatcher le premier ministre
britannique a bell face aux chauriens la
france soutien à la plainte du liban
contre israël aux nations unies
mais messieurs bonsoir un petit peu
d'oxygène pour ceux que la crise touche
de plein fouet pour ce que la dernière
ponction de la sécurité sociale sur leur
pouvoir d'achat n'aura pas épargné je
parlais surtout des familles à revenus
modestes et des personnes âgées c'est ce
que vous retiendrez d'abord de
l'ensemble des mesures arrêtées en
conseil des ministres à leur est destiné
donc 1 à soutenir l'économie un
dispositif pour le bâtiment et les
travaux publics que nous détaillerons
tout à l'heure et puis donc dans un
deuxième volet à aider les plus
défavorisés alors concrètement pour les
personnes âgées une allocation
exceptionnelle de 200 francs dans un
mois plus un relèvement du minimum
vieillesse pour les familles maintenant
d'abord sachez que exceptionnellement
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire sera
doublé même un peu plus elles étaient de
190 francs elle passera à 400 francs par
ailleurs pour les familles qui
bénéficient de ce que l'on appelle le
complément familial là la somme qu'elles
recevront en octobre passera de 400 à
600 francs du coup de pouce donc aux
familles et aux personnes âgées
à quelques jours des grands retours de
vacances et de la rentrée des classes
l'action décidée ce matin à trois
caractéristiques
d'abord elle est destinée aux revenus
modestes ceux qui sont les plus
sensibles modification du pouvoir
d'achat elle touche 1 6 3 millions de
familles celles qui ont un revenu moyen
d'environ 4000 francs ou plus élevé si
elles ont plus d'enfants elle touche
aussi deux millions de personnes âgées
celles qui reçoivent le minimum
vieillesse
deuxièmement cette action un caractère
familial très marqué puisque le
complément familial celui qui est
augmenté en octobre concerne les
familles ayant un enfant de moins de 3
ans où les familles de trois enfants et
plus
enfin cette action un caractère
exceptionnel il est vrai que pour les
personnes âgées cette mesure sera relayé
rapidement par une mesure définitive 40
francs par jour 1er décembre
mais pour les familles en attendant une
nouvelle augmentation des allocations
familiales
c'est uniquement en octobre que ces
sommes seront attribués
et effectivement ce sont des mesures
dites de rentrée scolaire et on sait que
traditionnellement les familles ont des
achats à faire des achats qu'on ne fait
qu'une fois par an à cette époque de
l'année cette allocation a donc un but
très précis elle est versée chaque année
aux familles qui ont les revenus les
plus modestes et cette année son montant
est largement majorées puisque on
touchera 400 francs par enfant à l'école
je vais prendre un exemple
une famille de trois enfants dont le
père est agent de maîtrise la mère ne
travaille pas trois enfants à l'école
elles touchent l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire cette famille touchera 3 x 400
francs 1200 francs et elle touchera en
plus le complément familial puisque elle
a trois enfants 600 francs voilà une
famille qui va avoir 1800 francs au mois
d'octobre eh bien vous me dites après et
bien après je crois que cela lui
permettra d'avoir moins de difficultés
et atténuera l'effet des charges et des
hausses qui sont intervenus et tout cela
coûtera au total familles personnes
âgées 2 milliards de francs la joute sq
automatiquement le smic sera relevé une
majoration de 2,2 pour cent à partir de
demain et cela nous amènera pour un mois
un salaire de 2150 de francs 80 centimes
le premier ministre a expliqué la
philosophie de ces mesures dans une
lettre qu'il a adressée aux partenaires
sociaux qu'il souhaite rencontrer dans
les prochaines semaines des rencontres
qui seront difficiles à en juger par les
premières réactions un dispositif sans
commune mesure avec les problèmes posés
dit la cgt soulagement momentanée
seulement dit la cfdt ces mesures ne
touche pas au fond de la politique menée
jusqu'à présent des mesures qui font de
20% des français assistés ajoute la
confédération des syndicats libres il
s'agit là d'une amorce destiné à
compléter d'urgence ti la cftc puis
force ouvrière accueille favorablement
les dispositions prévues à la fois donc
pour les personnes âgées et pour les
familles cela dit je vous le disais il
ya un deuxième volet à ces mesures
d'aujourd'hui deux milliards et demi de
francs qui seront consacré au soutien de
l'activité économique c'est à dire
essentiellement aux travaux publics et
aux bâtiments cela aussi ça nous
concerne car le bâtiment c'est le
logement de chacun d'entre nous et puis
c'est aussi un secteur qui peut
contribuer dans une certaine mesure à
réduire le chômage
en s'aventurant derrière cette pancarte
qu'on trouve sur tous les chantiers on
peut découvrir pourquoi le gouvernement
a choisi de relancer le secteur du
bâtiment et des travaux publics première
raison ce secteur est le premier
employeur de france 2 millions de
personnes y travaillent maçons
électriciens peintres charpentier etc au
total 9 % de la population active
deuxième raison c'est un secteur qui
produit énormément 300 milliards de
francs l'an dernier c'est à dire plus de
cinq fois la construction navale
l'aéronautique et l'industrie de
l'armement réunis enfin troisième raison
la plus importante
le bâtiment et les travaux publics
devront servir d'accélérateur avec deux
milliards et demi de francs le
gouvernement appuie sur la [ __ ] en
espérant relancer toute la machine
économique prenons le cas du bâtiment la
construction d'un immeuble fait
travailler des industries en amont les
tuileries les cimenteries l'équipement
sanitaire ou les textiles il faut savoir
que le bâtiment consomme un quart de
l'acier français c'est important pour la
sidérurgie
cet effet multiplicateur est valable
aussi en aval construire des logements
c'est vendre des appareils
électroménagers des meubles des
assurances au total en a calculé que
lorsque le bâtiment produit 100 francs
les autres secteurs de l'économie
produisent 200 francs c'est le
raisonnement que tient le gouvernement
il espère que les crédits injectés pour
le logement plus d'un milliard pour les
travaux publics les routes presque un
milliard et pour les économies d'énergie
400 millions vont générer des travaux
pour un montant bien supérieur
deux milliards et demi de crédit
devraient produire 7 milliards de
travaux alors prendre un petit peu de
recul field ceci et jugeons ces mesures
de circonstance alors est-ce qu'il
s'agit d'une simple compensation pour
ceux des français qui se sont sentis le
plus les états nîmois compensation
certainement mais faut voir dans quel
contexte ces mesures sont prises depuis
la fin de la guerre notre niveau de vie
a pratiquement été multiplié par trois
aujourd'hui c'est fini dit agi d'une
crise économique ou pas d'une guerre
économique les progrès sociaux seront
beaucoup moins rapide tout l'épisode en
train d'adopter des plans d'autérités
les derniers sont les norvégiens les
grecs les hollandais en france les
derniers rose notamment celle de la
sécurité sociale vient pénaliser les
familles les plus modestes et c'est le
président de la république quel est
justement demandé de compenser ces
hausses par des mesures appropriées pour
ces familles les plus modestes et sur un
plan économique celui dont un avantage
et permettront aux familles de consommer
davantage c'est à dire d'acheter
davantage par conséquent aux entreprises
de travailler plus bon alors ça c'est
l'aspect social du dispositif sur le
plan économique menace qu'on peut parler
vraiment d'une d'une relance un vraiment
relancé c'est un mot tabou au monsieur
raymond barre il s'agit d'un de mesures
de soutien de l'activité qui devrait
permette estime-t-on de créer environ
30000 emplois à travers cette injection
de deux milliards et demi dans
l'économie ceci dit toujours non pas de
relance parce que estime devront général
de l'économie parce que estime monsieur
raymond barre cela compromettrait
l'équilibré extérieur de la france
commerce extérieur et surtout la bonne
tenue du franc lefranc conduisait un
petit peu faible quand même ces
dernières semaines exhaler le
gouvernement tient un franc au fort
parce qu'avec un front for on paie moins
cher notre pétrole l'on peut penser
qu'avec les dernières hausses du pétrole
plus que jamais le gouvernement tient à
défendre sa monnaie avoir une monnaie
forte qu'ils disent est vrai une
quelques spéculations contre le franc
s'est joint à cannes et quelques petites
attaques parce que à cause de la
différence le taux d'inflation de
l'allemagne et la france certains
spéculent et en confiant qu'il faudrait
un séjour changé et parité entre les
deux monnaies mais pour l'instant c'est
une petite pression en train de
s'atténuer en tout cas on ne peut pas
parler de tomber sur le fond faut dire
aussi que l'emprunt d'état de 6
milliards dont je vous ai parlé au début
de l'été sera finalement émis le 4
septembre et puis que la hausse des
tarifs de la sncf dont je vous parlais
hier sera de 5 25% elle entrera en
vigueur à partir de samedi mais au fait
qu'ils aient la possibilité de prendre
d'ici là biya l'actuel tarifs billet
vous le savez valable un mois voilà pour
ceux qui prennent le train pour ceux qui
roulent surtout en automobile encore une
pause au conseil des ministres pour vous
détailler les mesures destinées à faire
baisser le chiffre des accidents douze
mille l'an dernier vous le rappelle on
va encore se montrer plus sévère avec
les conducteurs en infraction et l'on
prévoit un tarif des amendes davantage
proportionnées à la gravité des excès de
vitesse le projet par le toujours de la
possibilité de payer directement
l'amande sur le lieu de l'infraction par
le même d'une aggravation de ce montant
si l'automobiliste run apprécié la
justice finit par lui donner tort mais
là encore rien n'est sûr car il s'agit
je vous rappelle d'un projet de loi que
peuvent amender les parlementaires
encore une contravention mais si vous
l'oubliez cette fois dans la boîte à
gants l'amande passera peut-être du
simple au double ou même triplera si la
justice une fois saisie confirme
l'infraction
voilà si ce n'est encore la lettre du
moins l'esprit du projet de loi qui sera
déposée dès la prochaine session
parlementaire
objectif épinglé tous les réfractaires
aux papillons tous ceux qui négligent ou
qui tarde à régler leurs amendes et en
france ils sont légion 10 % seulement
des automobilistes parisiens payent
spontanément leurs amendes par timbre
est à peine 60% des amendes forfaitaires
sont réellement transformer en amendes
pénales fixe une impunité préjudiciable
bien sûr au bon respect du code de la
route mais aussi un manque à gagner non
négligeable pour le trésor public un
milliard de contraventions impayées en
1976 demain le tarif dont des amendes
sera peut être proportionnelles à la
gravité des excès de vitesse sanctionnés
pas de pitié pour les chauffards avait
dit il ya quelques jours le ministre de
l'intérieur pas de sursis pour les
contrevenants dit-on aujourd'hui en
substance au ministère de la justice
alors attention si vous oubliez de payer
on ne vous oubliera pas telle est du
moins le sens des dispositions en
préparation
rappelant avec jean marc loos qu'il
s'agit de mesures qui reste conditionné
au vote des députés et les sénateurs un
vote qui nous savons dans ce genre de
domaine n'est pas toujours acquis un mot
sur la politique maintenant pour vous
dire que finalement les communistes ont
dit oui aux socialistes qui leur avait
proposé une rencontre un échange de vues
avec le ps peut s'avérer utile vient de
faire savoir le bureau politique du
parti communiste et ce malgrès des
contradictions flagrantes dans les
propos du parti socialiste ajoutons
place du colonel fabien résultats
concrets pierre bérégovoy se rendra à
l'invitation du communiste charles
fiterman
l'actualité hors de nos frontières
maintenant avec d'abord essentiellement
bien sûr les suite de l'assassinât de
lord mountbatten et de 18 soldats
britanniques en ulster le premier
ministre britannique madame thatcher
s'est d'ailleurs rendue aujourd'hui sur
place auprès des rescapés des attentats
et elle a pour la circonstance revêtu la
tenue des parachutistes britanniques
avant de se mêler à la foule de bell
face nous rejoignons allons notre envoyé
spécial serge me serait
incontestablement le premier ministre
britannique vient de marquer des points
d'abord en se rendant à belfast au
chevet des paras blessés lundi dernier
et puis on se promenant tout
l'après-midi à ahmad en plein fief de
l'ira et puis aussi parce que le pape
n'ira pas en alster aggravant ainsi son
désaveu des extrémistes catholiques et
puis enfin parce qu'elle n'a pas cédé à
la tentation de la répression dans ce
moment critique
évidemment ces trucs lüthi pas seulement
pour le peuple britannique le peuple
irlandais de north bay mais aussi pour
le peuple il remet tout ce n'est ce pas
et le madame monsieur
jean suau y
elle va faire quelque chose avec le
gouvernement irlandais est pour moi j'ai
l'impression que le prochain
événement et il s'agit de quelque chose
avec les hirondelles de doubler n'est ce
pas par exemple
de ratifier de signer deux conventions
européennes
contre terrorisme aussi de tomber
d'accord avec une traité ou neurones
jugement d'extradition
avec le gouvenement peau tonique
dans le même temps les mesures de
sécurité concernant la famille royale
ont été renforcées comme ont été
renforcées les rondes de police devant
les domiciles des personnalités qui
pourraient être menacés et pour la
première fois les policiers en anglais
ont un pistolet dans la poche
quant aux obsèques de lord mountbatten
on sait maintenant qu elles auront lieu
mercredi prochain à l'abbaye de
westminster décor de l'amiral de son
petit fils de lady braeburn arriveront
par avion demain en début d'après-midi
dans le hampshire où résident et
l'amiral il y aura là le duc d'edimbourg
et le prince charles plus tard après les
funérailles nationales lord mountbatten
sera enterré à rome ses abeilles selon
ses dernières volontés
il rend toujours la violence 14
exécution après une mutinerie à la
prison de tabriz et puis un peu plus au
kurdistan toujours la répression je
crois que le monde entier aura été
impressionné par cette photo publiée par
l' agence you buy photos d'exécutions
sommaires vous le voyez aussi on sent
quand même de la part de la ja de la
charia thomas lary numéro deux de la
hiérarchie religieuse en iran une
volonté de négociation
au pied des montagnes kurdes la ville de
pavés l'une des dernières places fortes
tombées aux mains des gardiens de la
révolution
une ville pratiquement désertes évacuées
par la grande majorité de ses habitants
qui redoutent les représailles de
l'armée iranienne et des hommes de
l'ayatollah khomeini les combattants
kurdes de son parti et aussi avec leurs
familles dans la dernière vide entre
leurs mains mahabad à 100 km d'ici c'est
là également que sont réfugiés les chefs
du parti démocratique kurde désormais
interdits l'ordre règne à paver celui de
l'armée iranienne et des gardiens de la
révolution qui ont exécuté une bonne
vingtaine de prisonniers accusés de
trahison et de collaboration avec les
combattants kurdes
d'accord intervenu entre certains
représentants kurdes et le gouvernement
n'a pas provoqué l'enthousiasmé même si
les kurdes acceptent de laisser l'armée
iranienne entrée dans la dernière ville
qu'ils contrôlent même si les gardiens
de la révolution chargé du maintien de
l'ordre seront recrutés sur place on
n'oublie pas ici que l'ayatollah
khomeini avait promis aux kurdes un
châtiment exemplaire
une rencontre aujourd'hui à alger entre
georges marchais le secrétaire général
du front polisario et deux hommes ont
qualifié de coup de force et
d'agressions l'occupation du rio d or
par le marque et puis la france et le
liban un élément nouveau aujourd'hui le
conseil des ministres à paris a condamné
et a décidé de soutenir la plainte du
liban contre israël plainte déposée au
conseil de sécurité à la crois qu'on
peut parler d'éléments nouveaux dans la
diplomatie française quand même fort
portal oui je crois qu'on nous parlait
d'un isolement diplomatique croissant
d'israël ils ont ces décisions notamment
du gouvernement français et a raison je
crois même aux états unis où l'opinion y
bonne traditionnellement qu israël d'un
trouble croissant de l'opinion
américaine devant ces bombardements
répétés qui ont été menées par les
israéliens au liban parce que les
américains ont vu cela sur leur écran de
télévision comme vous l'avez vu vous
même puisque nous avons montré ces
bombardements ces jours derniers sur
antenne 2 alors donc je rappelle les
fêtes il y a eu pendant des jours et des
semaines bombardements direct des
israéliens ou bien amenez depuis les
enclaves chrétiennes qui sont à la
frontière israël ou 16 des bombardements
très important avec de l'artillerie très
lourde et 155 notamment qui ont fait
beaucoup de dégâts au liban et même des
victimes humaines et donc le fait
nouveau ce soir c'est que la france à
l'issue du conseil des ministres a fait
savoir qu'elle allait soutenir les rôles
ainsi déposé par beyrouth contre israël
et les termes sont sévères d'ailleurs le
communiqué du conseil des ministres mme
condamne les actes de violence entrepris
contre le liban ses ressortissants et
ses institutions en termes très vifs
voilà alors bon l'ambassade d'israël à
paris bien entendu on dit non israël n'a
pas l'intention de changer son attitude
parce qu israël défend son intégrité
c'est pour sa défense
est ce que le conseil de sécurité a les
moyens de faire vraiment changer les
choses il ne faut pas espérer un miracle
quelle est la solution du côté français
on dit il ya tout de même une amorce de
solution c'est la finul la fameuse force
des nations unies pour le liban la force
internationale n'est ce pas est la
solution aux tel qu'on l'imaginé ça
pourrait être justement d'augmenter et
le nombre très les effectifs des postes
d'observation des nations unies dans le
sud liban pour servait justement de
tampon entre les parties intéressées
bien pour en finir tout à fait avec
l'actualité internationale j'ai eu
entre-temps pans d'une part lier phillip
chatenet qui de belfast où fait savoir
que nous pourrons entendre dans le tout
dernier journal celui d'art est l'autre
vers 23h30 nous pourrons entendre sa
première correspondance sur place
voici maintenant notre troisième enquête
sur le bilan des vacances vous avez pu
suivre tout d'abord nos reportages dans
le midi et normandie et bien ce soir
nous allons prendre un peu d'altitude et
voir comment s'achève la saison en
montagne jean luc dufour a planté son
bivouac dans les alpes plus précisément
à chamonix
ce qu'on retiendra de l'ère des vacances
79 c'est que les dépenses des français
baisse d'un ton une tendance sûrement
général mais qui s'accentue dans les
montagnes de la région rhône-alpes
puisqu'elles ont été moins fréquentées
cette année à cause d'un hiver
interminable et d'un printemps pourri
les vacanciers avides de soleil ont
préféré ne pas prendre de risque en
choisissant les plages du sud à la
montagne comme ailleurs les premiers
touchés sont les hôteliers et les
restaurateurs
exception faite peut-être de chamonix
mecque du tourisme alpin qui grâce aux
très nombreux étrangers jouit d'une
situation privilégiée même si et
chamonix est une station privilégié
parce qu'elle reçoit beaucoup de
clientèle étrangère la clientèle
française a diminué ses dépenses c'est à
dire que le client l'industriel qui
venaient ici et qu'ils dépensaient qui
habitait karine nombreux invités et bien
depuis deux ou trois ans le sens que les
choses ont bien changé et souvent ils se
bornent à prendre nous simples pension
une situation qui illustre bien la boxe
toujours plus grande pour le camping
caravaning moins cher que les séjours en
hôtel mais là aussi des restrictions
cette année du camp 4 étoiles on passe
aux trois étoiles et 1 ci dessus
côté restauration est fondue savoyarde
l'addition trop lourde à digérer en
période de régime économique pousse de
nombreux vacanciers à préférer les
déjeuners sur l'herbe une tendance qui
fait le bonheur des épiciers et des
grandes surfaces ça nous veillons quand
même à ne pas dépenser plus que nous
pouvons vous allez souvent restaurant de
temps en temps lorsque les prix ne sont
pas trop trop trop excessif salut view
n'a fait attention parce que thomas
aebischer on sait donc cramponner dans
cette région de classes y est comme
ailleurs pour ne pas trop dépenser
surtout que de plus en plus les français
désirent absolument garder quelques
jours pour partir en hiver mais malgré
de légères restrictions les magasins de
sport ont fait de bonnes affaires dans
l'ensemble la saison s'est très bien
passé mais on constate que les clients
achètent quand même un petit peu moins
cher étant donné qu'ils se rendent
compte qu'ils s'en servent très peu dans
le temps pendant leurs vacances et
hésite un peu maintenant acheter cher
mais vu la masse de man u qui
fréquentent chamonix la saison s'est
très bien passé
par contre et malgré les deux sans trois
interventions de la gendarmerie depuis
le début de l'année dans le massif du
mont blanc pas d'économies sur le nombre
de tués 39 ans 78 41 ans 79 les blessés
ils sont beaucoup plus nombreux cette
année 230 on passe à 175
il ne faudrait pourtant pas oubliés même
s'ils ne se comptabilise pas ce qui
restera l'essentiel pour des milliers de
vacanciers les souvenirs
la fête continue c'était le titre des
mémoires qu'avait entreprises marie
marquer elle en était à son cinquième
volume ce sera le dernier marie marqué
est morte ce matin à l'âge de 84 ans au
soir d'une vie je crois bien remplie
marie marqué appartenait au dernier
carré des monstres sacrés elle avait
débuté à la comédie française en étant
tragédienne et quitter les planches en
disant des sketches comiques dans les
cabarets elle fut célébré pour sa beauté
par de nombreux écrivains et de 20 elle
même écrivain cette beauté fanée le
succès de ses mémoires a poussé ravir
son premier roman à 83 ans dans ses
mémoires en cinq tomes elle compta
comment elle avait débuté avec sarah
bernhardt est aimé par edmond rostand
comment elle avait épousé maurice
escande grand sociétaire de la comédie
française et puis victor france n grande
vedette du muet elle avait été aussi
l'égérie d'un homme politique en vrai
par dieu du temps où le palais bourbon
entretenait des rapports étroits avec la
comédie française
elle qui décrivit avec l'impudeur royal
des femmes qui se sentent belles jusque
dans leurs erreurs grande jusque dans
leur faute séduisante jusque dans leurs
faiblesses comme dans les tragédies
s'obliger vous connaissant mes bras vous
en reçu mon pays mes enfants pour vous
j'ai tout quitté
réservez vous ce prix à ma fidélité
quels fruits espères-tu de tant de
violence
et frémir d'horreur si je rends le
silence et que me direz-vous qu'il du
cèdre en un dieu alors heures de vous
voir actu pire est à mes yeux
quand tu seras mon crime
et le sort qui n'a qu'un
amour est pas moins
sans nous les plus graves on ne déplore
que pour vous j'ai versé par vous faible
jeunes eux que je tiens embrasser
les livrer dans l'esprit de ce funeste
doute
marqué disparaît donc aujourd'hui à
l'âge de 84 à condé-sur-l'escaut près de
valenciennes on connaît maintenant le
montant exact de la somme volée à la
perception de cette ville 16 millions de
francs c'est encore pire que ce qu'on
avait d'abord annoncé c'est une somme
énorme sport d'antenne 2010 michel
hidalgo nous dévoilait le nom des
présélectionnés pour le match qui
disputera en suède le 5 septembre alors
il a retenu 16 joueurs une petite
surprise aucun marseillais ni trésor qui
a demandé du même être tenu à l'écart de
cette sélection ni didier six alors il y
à vous allez le voir si stéphanois et 4
n'empêche voulait se découvrir le nom de
ses seize joueurs donc dropsy ray
battiston bossis janvion specht lopez
pour le milieu de terrain bathenay large
aux platines et michel et pour les
attaquants vous le voyez amis cela
compte pécout rocheteau et zimako et
puis pénis dans le tournoi de flushing
meadow qui se déroule actuellement à new
york
le français patrice dominguez a été
éliminée dès le premier tour par
l'américain à steve coup le vide sans
trois sets secs 6 0 6 1 7 6 de nouvelles
maintenant de david de ce cyclone qui se
dirige vers la martinique des vents de
240 km heure sont attendus toutes les
communications sont coupées en ce moment
avec la guadeloupe et la martinique
air france retard tous ses vols sur les
antilles puis spécialement ceux sur
verre vers la martinique alors je vous
conseille si vous devez vous rendre dans
ces régions d'appeler auparavant le 320
14 44 et puis il faut dire compte tenu
de la violence exceptionnelle de ce
cyclone que le plan orsec a été
déclenché et puis hier soir que des
mesures de protection hélène
d'évacuation de la population ont été
prises et je crois qu'il faut essayer
avec vous ou laurent brault m suivez
heure par heure la progression de ce
cyclone et nous avons dit qu'il est
difficile car toutes les communications
sont coupées il faut donc expliquer un
peu comment ce moment-ci claude
lacouture on sait qu'ils se forment
toujours au même endroit cyclone entre
les tropiques là où la mer est chaude
plus de 25 degrés et là où des ventes
sauce contraire vont faire virevolter
l'air le 22 août il ya donc quelques
jours une zone où la pression de l'air
est plus faible s'est formée au large de
l'afrique est dès lors sa route est
irréversible vers l'ouest vers les
antilles vous propose de suivre le
périple avec ces images remarquables
transmises par les satellites et par la
météorologie origine nationale française
voici nous sommes le 26 août à 15 heures
voici l'amérique voici les antilles
voici david il vient de là-bas des côtes
de l'afrique deuxième photographie cette
fois ci c'est le 27 août 14h30 david est
ici les antilles six voiliers il a
gonflé pourquoi bien exactement comme
quand vous vider un lavabo l'eau
s'engouffre en tourbillonnant vers le
trou central du lavabo ici l'air c'est
un gouffre au centre il mesure plus de
800 km de large il continue vers l'ouest
une journée après 28 août 14h30 les
antilles sont ici d'un vide a légèrement
faibli mais il se rapproche
dangereusement des côtes de la
guadeloupe et de la martinique enfin
dernière image plus catastrophique elle
est le 29 août 79 aujourd'hui 8 heures
vous voyez les petites îles sont déjà
dans les nuages la catastrophe est
inévitable tout est prêt pour
l'accueillir sur terre avec tout ce qui
accompagne ses dires des vents de 120 km
à l'heure de moyenne des pointes de 180
ou 200 des vagues de huit mètres nous
saurons dans quelques heures si les
précautions prises ont été suffisantes
car ça fait tout de même dix ans qu'on
n'avait pas vu un cyclone de cette force
dans cette région enfin une dernier
point quel est l'avenir de ce site vous
propose une dernière fois de regarder la
carte
david va se diriger vers le nord-ouest
il va sans doute mourir au large de la
floride mais déjà à l'autre bout
regardez là bas un autre cyclone se
former nous ne pouvons pas encore savoir
s'il sera aussi bien entre premiers le
seront dans les prochains jours oui la
météorologie ne permet pas encore de
tuer le cyclone de l'étouffer dans
l'oeuf elle permet au moins grâce au
satellite de le voir se former et donc
de prévenir le danger dans des régions
malheureusement c'est une catastrophe
classique alors nous avons un envoyé
spécial sur place qui nous appellera
peut-être dans le dernier journal en
tout cas je pense qu'avec l'autre pourra
nous donner des nouvelles un petit peu
plus fraîche donc de ce cycle audi en
principe aurait atteint il y à quelques
heures les côtes de la martinique puis
tout ça nous amène à vous parler de la
météo en métropole aujourd'hui il a fait
beau sur l'ensemble du pays les
températures vous le voyez encore marqué
une légère hausse pour demain et bien de
la bretagne la vendée et des pyrénées au
massif central le ciel sera nuageux et
même parfois menaçants des ondées
orageuses pourront se produire notamment
près des pyrénées et du massif central
sur le reste du pays regardez bien le
temps sera frais et souvent brumeux le
matin puis bien ensoleillé dans la
journée voilà je pense que maintenant
nous sommes en mesure de pouvoir
entendre le premier ministre qui
s'exprimait pendant ce journal sur une
antenne concurrentes sur tf1 et qui a
répondu au flot de critiques qui a
déversé vous le savez au moins de
l'anniversaire de ses trois ans de
pouvoir à matignon nous l'entendons donc
réagir et faire une sorte de bilan de
ces trois ans comme premier ministre
résumé la situation
je dirais en 1976 l'économie française
allait à la dérive en 1979 l'économie
française est en situation de faire face
de faire face aux difficultés et à
l'heure actuelle la pression que
certains veulent donner c'est qu'il y à
une situation qui n'est pas maîtrisable
vous avez parlé du pessimisme du
catastrophisme alors qu'en réalité pour
terminer net sur quelles sont vos
prévisions à partir justement de cette
impression que l'économie parents
débâcle tout peut arriver quelles sont
vos prévisions pour l'hiver disons que
l'an dernier nous aurons pendant
quelques mois une situation difficile je
ne vais jamais caché cette situation
difficile tiendra au fait que nous
aurons à payer le surcroît de facture
pétrolière à ce que nous enregistrons
une pression sur nos prix et à ce qu' il
y aura un certain ralentissement de
l'activité économique que nous essayons
de compenser par les mesures que mon
preuves mais la france à des êtres
et c'est ce que je voudrais dire ce soir
ceux qui
critiquent l'action gouvernementale ce
qui aujourd'hui font du catastrophisme
du catastrophisme
cela ne se rendent pas compte de la
capacité des français le surmonter les
difficultés auxquelles le pays à faire
face et il prend les mises d'ajouter
quand on doit gouverner on doit faire ni
le matamore ni jolicoeur temps comporte
la charge on doit en assumer la
responsabilité la tâche demain il ya un
tiercé à vincennes dans le prix de
vendée voici donc comme d'habitude les
pronostics de piran bresse elle a choisi
huit chevaux que vous découvrez
maintenant sur votre écran le 2 le 16 le
17 le 7 le 13 le 3 le vin et le 18 et
puis aujourd'hui mercredi c'était le
jour du tirage du loto pour gagner allez
jouer les numéros suivants le 4 le 8 le
15 le 16 le 20 et le 25 avec comme
numéro complémentaire est le 33 voilà
vos prochains rendez vous avec
l'information d'antenne 2 tout d'abord
vers 23 heures le dernier journal b avec
l'eau des puits demain à 12h40
cinquantaine de midi présenté par daniel
bilalian ce journal est pas tout à fait
terminée je vous en ai gardé en effet
pour la fin les toutes premières images
que vous découvrez à l'instant de la
planète saturne c'est en effet la
première fois qu'une sonde en
l'occurrence américaines pioneer 11 se
rapproche autant de saturne à la vitesse
de 33 mille kilomètres heure voilà ce
journal est tout à fait terminé je vous
souhaite une très très bonne soirée puis
j'espère vous retrouver demain à la même
heure